les hôpitaux débordent partout au canada
particulièrement au québec la majorité
des lits aux soins intensifs sont
occupés par des personnes non vaccinées
au cours des dernières semaines il ya
des économistes des fiscalistes qui ont
proposé d'évoluer d'évaluer pardon des
solutions fiscales pour encourager les
personnes non vaccinées à se faire
vacciner avec nous ce soir daniel paillé
économistes et fiscalistes qui propose
d'instaurer un incitatif fiscal le
vaccin peau bonsoir monsieur paillé
bonsoir monsieur l'idée serait de faire
payer les personnes non vaccinées pour
les soins reçus à l'hôpital des
personnes non vaccinées qui sont bien
sûr hospitalisé en quoi consiste votre
proposition monsieur payer
savez on a eu toutes sortes d'incitatifs
le premier ministre et le ministre de la
santé
ils sont à court d'imagination pour
inviter les gens à aller se faire
vacciner on a organisé des nôtres et on
en est c'est à peu près tout et moi j'ai
comme un peu penser en dehors de la
boîte en disant écoutez on a déjà la
carte d'assurance maladie dès l'instant
où elle à l'hôpital on sait ce besoin de
vacciner ou non on a des jeunes numéro
d'assurance sociale on paie chacun nos
impôts donc on a atteint justin
passeport fiscale pourquoi pas ajoutez
le passeport vaccinale avec ça et de
dire aux gens vous avez le droit de ne
pas croire vous avez le droit de ne pas
être vaccinés mais vous occupez 90% des
soins intensifs ça coûte très cher ça
prend de la place où les gens qui ont
payé toute leur vie leurs impôts alors
pourquoi ne pas tout simplement leur
dire bah écoutez si jamais vous êtes en
danger si jamais vous devez aller à
l'hôpital on va vous recevoir les pros
question de doazit modérateur ou
d'arrêter des gens et de dire à la fin
quand vous sortirez ben on rajoutera sur
votre impôt à payer le coût que ça fait
d'être à l'hôpital c'est d'occuper un
lit qui aurait été occupé par quelqu'un
de tout mais c'est une forme de ticket
modérateur dans un sens parce que les
gens un instant là je vais attendre
d'être très très malade avant de me
rendre à l'hôpital
ce célèbre à vous d'y aller ou pas y
aller le ticket modérateur c'était avant
locale on vous demande et aveo 5 d'or
dans votre poche ou 20 $ si l'on tire à
moi c'est pas ça du tout se dire après
coup vous avez occupé un lit qui aurait
dû être pour ceux qui en ont besoin mais
si vous continuez dans votre idée de ne
pas être victime et je comprends qu'elle
dit mais je comprends même temps on peut
se payer les non vaccinés
peu importe ce qu'on peut en penser peut
aussi des impôts et pelles système de
santé et endroit où on doit à ce système
universel est ce que ça vient pas
entraver le droit universel à
l'accessibilité aux soins et c'est à
dire que nous sommes dans une situation
exceptionnelle et moi je fais une
proposition un peu exceptionnelle en
voisin oui tout le monde a payé des
impôts oui vous avez droit oui vous
faites un accident parce que vous avez
mal conduit ou et vous avez un cancer
parce que vous avez fui toute votre vie
ça c'est le régime global vous n'êtes
pas contagieux actuellement on a une
maladie qui est extrêmement contagieuse
il ya moyen gratuitement de recevoir un
vaccin pour être moins contagieux ou ne
pas être contagieux mais si vous vous
entêtez à dire non j'y crois pas
de deux choses l'une ou bien vous allez
payer si vous deviez à l'hôpital ou bien
vous y croyez tellement pas que vous
n'irez pas l'hôpital et donc que vous
n'aurez rien à payer est ce que vous
semblez tracé cette ligne là cet endroit
de la contagion mais des gens qui
pourraient dire les gens qui fument et
qui continuent de fumer sachant très
bien que ça conduit malheureusement à
des maladies possibles liées au décès
finalement est ce que est ce que où
est-ce qu'on impose la ligne parce qu'on
on pourrait aussi imposer une surtaxe
aux fumeurs par exemple ben il ya déjà
des taxes ou les fumées les jaune et
noir sont déjà beaucoup de taxes c'est
ça que vous dites est aussi des gens qui
pètent le de haut niveau de leur permis
de conduire pour des super cadré mais
moi je veux pas de chasse moi je veux
juste arrivé en disant tu as l'argent je
suis un libre penseur je pense un petit
coup de gauche un peu en dehors de moi
mais ce que c'est faisable on a deux
systèmes ben oui pourquoi pas gardons ça
st et ajoutons à l'impôt à payer le coût
d'un lit d'hôpital dont on dit que c'est
5000 à rabat jo ou en soins intensifs
dix mille dollars par jour alors
j'appelle ça un incitatif est-ce que
c'est punitif après coup mais évidemment
mais chacun assume ses responsabilités
et n'allons pas plus loin on a une
mesure exceptionnelle devint un fléau
exceptionnel le reste c'est reparti au
gouvernement donc de façon nouvelle de
dire une facture symbolique par exemple
pour les non vaccinés pour leur dire
regardez combien ça coûte
c'est le passé
non c'est parce que ça fait des mois
qu'on est dans les symboles on a fait
toutes sortes de conférences de braise
on incite les gens ont de fait le tri
pour gagner des prix pour ce qu elles ne
seraient vaccinés ont bien un moment
donné il faut que ça bouge est bon mon
idée elle a été lancée dans l'univers
comme ça et puis ça fait une semaine
qu'on en parle pas mieux couverts maman
d'après nous l'apprennent port j'avais
voies larges et ça vous souhaiter une
bonne année parce que vous l'avez fait à
mon égard oui vous avez tout à fait
raison mais d'agnès parce que je lui dis
14 fois depuis le début de l'émission
mais je vous souhaite une bonne année
daniel paillé merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup monsieur fignon
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh